hey i'm cinematoskin and that's
pewdiepie and today we're checking out
extreme cheapskates the world's cheapest
date
and then i tell a little bit about the
video which i usually don't know but you
know
that's actually pretty good
like that yeah i should probably do that
anyway guys today we're watching uh
the world's cheapest date have you ever
been on a cheap date ken
um look yes i have i have been on cheap
date
i used to have a tried and true way to
save money on dates
i'd meet someone new and i want to take
them out you take it to the park
it's free oh they they think it's
romantic and cute
like some ice cream you can get for like
a dollar there you can like see some
ducks and some animals and it's in the
place and then you know you just walk
around and enjoy yourselves bring some
old
molded bread to feed the ducks and then
the geese attack you because they're
freaking mean
yeah and then you'll run away together
holding hands the jeep yes
frolicking and the old man shaking his
face at you
kids perfect date priceless
and if you're in the city wow why
what do you think someone may offer you
something you know under the bridge
they'd be like hey look at me
the state gets better and better i'm
there ken
then there's action you know oh man the
whole thing no i obviously are you got
married it all makes sense
we're watching the cheapest date however
oh how do you get cheaper from zero
this guy makes money during this thing
yeah they pay him oh my god how can they
possibly make this cheaper i want to see
this
[Music]
cincinnati oh they go to cincinnati
that's how they make it cheaper
cincinnati ohio the people
that play sucks of course
[Laughter]
it all makes it he's like all right they
live in l.a i'm like guys
no let's go to let's go to ohio it'll be
way better trust me
what is the fifth third bank that makes
no sense
who named that building
fifth fifth or third i can't remember
put it on someone in pr right now that's
watching this is like freaking out oh my
god
tear them
[Music]
we got logan paul here and juggling
kind of looks like oh my god dude
my name is greg insco i'm 29 years old
i've lived in cincinnati ohio all my
life
i'm a zumba dance instructor and i'm an
extreme cheapskate
i guess they don't pay well on zumba huh
oh he's gotta be cheap right
why was he wearing it lately what what
is happening here is that i don't know
he's also got
a look sexy on his shirt what is that
that's sexy he knows it's sexy and he
knows it
i'll do a clinical study anytime i can
because those pay really good money
oh okay that's the reason i had to get
hell yeah
somehow what what
why is that a thing i don't they have
draw likes from the car
this dude is cool yeah
all right that's how you get respect in
america teach a super class direct get
your hot drugs out
and then do clinical studies he paid he
lets people pay him to give him stuff
there's this tick tock channel where
they they ask people when nice cars like
hey what do you do for a living he's
like
clinical studies big the one i always
see is it's a ford ranger
or when i got dang spaceship what's that
one
no what the hell look at look at that we
know that we in the spaceship
oh man y'all think y'all hard y'all
think y'all hard oh
so i got no [ __ ] like this hey i don't
know man we open a damn spaceship
[Laughter]
oh man y'all think y'all hard y'all
think y'all this is it oh
troy ain't got no [ __ ] like this hang on
man we open a damn spaceship
that's the one i've seen first i don't
know what the sound bites from i don't
know
jesus christ well that's it what's the
point of leaning the hydraulics to the
right like to get out of the car or
easier drive a car like this and you're
getting down the trap you know you pull
up on the curb you got to lean it down
look out the window and you know make
the deal
oh i see i'm really lucky the clinical
study that i found online
was paying the same amount i had to put
uh ointment in my butt
but i got a car out of it so it was well
worth it you got a car for some
ointment dude all right put some stuff
in my butt for a car come on
what you gonna give me a car you
thinking about it
i uh well no no i'm not
i had to put those [ __ ] pills up my
ass one time
get your suppository and i didn't get a
car for it
this is [ __ ] all i got was shame and
pain
dude i hate this guy now god
suppositories are
there's no there's no feeling quite like
it you know no it isn't
when it gets to that point of no return
you're just kind of like oh
it's gone and you just you don't know
how to feel about it
it's like you're learning about a thing
that your body can do that you wish you
never knew
oh i can eat through that hole cool
like there's there's some resistance and
all of a sudden there's not and it's
gone you're like
i'm glad i'm glad i can laugh at these
painful memories with you ken i
appreciate that i'm glad i can relate
where
am i all right
maybe he just oh god hey kids when you
grow up this is the kind of sh you have
to do as well all right
i'll stick a finger off your ass
you think that you think not going to
the doctor is cool it ain't cool when
you get old there
ain't nothing cool about it you just use
the window squeegees
and you can really wash your whole car
with it i don't know who would spend
money on a car wash when you can wash it
yourself right here
i mean why does it keep having the car
lent like that
stop it he's on because he's cool man
he's cool and he's also taking up two
parking spots hell yeah that's the
american way
one of the most illegal things i do can
hear in in uk we have like family
parking
that are way more spacious so that the
kids don't hit the car i always go there
i'm calling the cops i'm calling the
cops right now hello
every time mars is like no don't do it
i'm just like yeah i'm doing it i got a
big car
all right i can't it can't fit anywhere
else stupid is it a big car is it a big
car for the uk because everything's it's
a
shut up it's huge it's
so good it's huge it's yeah okay is
there a fine for it
double parking i'm sure they don't
appreciate no the family parking
there's a law hell yeah i'm breaking the
law [ __ ]
71 of drivers have seen parent and child
spaces being
oh boo misused i can rattle them out i
have a big car
one in ten hey i'm a minority let's go
it's the family parking why are you
taking the like there's a family in need
out there and you're waiting
a special it makes no sense [ __ ] up
oh next you're gonna be like why do
handicapped people get special parking
you know come on
park in their parking spots too that is
not the same
at all it might as well be your
disregard for humanity shame on you
you know what i also do you know i i
have a hybrid car so sometimes i stop on
the electric you have a huge hybrid car
how's that even happen
two motors [ __ ] just gotta fit in there
motors
yeah i stop at the electric places
sometimes cause it's a hybrid
even though i don't charge it
so you have the electric motor but you
just use the gas motor
yeah it's better taxes that way all
right so what do
you park like the gas side in the other
parking spot in your electric side and
the other one
hell yeah that's the way i get two
spaces that way it's a hybrid right
right
why am i emitting all these secrets no i
don't know
all right
hi welcome to my condo i got pretty
lucky
one of the ladies from zumba said hey my
grandpa just passed away if you want to
live in our condo for free in return i'm
supposed to mow her lawn but you know
you can't beat free rent
is all granddad's stuff still in the
house i guess so that's kind of weird
he just died and she's like hey you want
to move into my
take over i don't i feel like that is
not how that happened it's like oh
you're
so your dad died oh yeah i bet there's
like a household empty and that no one
uses now huh
i bet i bet that the lawn is all
overgrown huh something
great or something i'll give you free
zumba classes if you give me a place to
live and she's like
yeah stay in here oh man why
there's some lady eating granddad's
ashes
why is there a coat rack in the bathroom
let's see that's your has to hang your
towels you face the lovely face towels
come on that makes no sense yeah there's
that in the corner though
that little thing in the corner what is
that it's like a
cup dispenser oh yeah that's actually
not a bad idea i'm not getting
one of them nice
and uses old spice definitely saving
money uh this is all from when the guy
oh you wear fancy deodorants kane no
well i don't
or you got a like a high-end brand
deodorant or something is there a
high-end brand deodorant
yeah i i use it really what is it
because you know i'm over here living
this luxurious youtube life
moved australia and everything i want to
smell good sorry yeah
i need i need to get the nicer things in
life i need i need name brand deodorant
name brand toothpaste and floss
absolutely
oh i have that too yeah it's uh we got
gucci floss over there what do you got
no but i got fancy toothpaste i'm living
in life ken it's got licorice flavor
it's delicious
one day you'll get to me at my level you
just tell me that the licorice is
delicious
yeah you're you're from the south you
gotta like
i eat the vomit chocolate and even i
know twizzlers
what's wrong with twistler they're
freaking nasty
there's like what is nest it doesn't
even taste this is not even real
licorice
that makes it even worse oh my god
you're not american i am this is why you
moved out i understand that
you know you lost your powers nobody
likes twizzlers just like the candy corn
nobody likes that either yeah yeah
what do you like then i don't even know
minge
it was a minch it sounds like a like a
like a hair disease or something do you
have looks on my mind that's the main
geographer
what do you like then i mean sour patch
kids you know reese's pieces
are jerez's oh sour patch kids are great
i actually we have friends sending us us
they're great are we actually they
haven't been in uk
you know you can't get those i gotta
smuggle them in for you yeah
i love that i love the really really
sour ones
that makes your stomach feel like it's
gonna turn itself inside out
what is wrong with you i think we're
like connecting on a level here and then
all of a sudden
what [ __ ] but you don't even park at
that family
you have a family you didn't even park
there at bay and you're like oh can we
really do this
well i don't have a car right now so
please subscribe
oh yeah what car what car are you
getting an odyssey
yeah we are a family man
about to go drop my kids off at soccer
practice you know me
gotta get that people mover hell yeah
that's not a bad car seems good oh it's
a honda
let's go it's okay i'll do what every
other youtuber does out and i'll just go
rent like a ferrari or something for a
video oh yeah
yeah i got to be cool like that yeah
when i was in uh visiting you in l.a or
in l.a for whatever reason you had a you
had like a really
fancy sports car yeah and look at you
now
yeah you know things change
well now i want to buy a sports car and
ken is like
you'll get over it you'll get it you'll
get out of your system eventually
i'm gonna park that in two parking spots
you're gonna put hydraulics in that
thing shoot
yes i got to know yeah oh yeah all right
we gotta watch this
guy for some reason i didn't have any
furniture it worked out nice
these are my roommates we got raj and
kevin here it's painful bringing women
back that wasn't awkward at all what the
[ __ ] was that
judging kevin here are they like do we
pretend like we're reading or do we
acknowledge the camera or
a matching short gang let's see
they're reading about odyssey hondas
they probably pulled that out of the
following camera back in the background
it's got grandpa's wheel in it or
something oh my god
oh yeah this much funny damn painful
bringing women back
to the apartment because furniture
you're not bringing anyone back here
bringing nobody back to that place
what are you talking about oh it's so
painful with all the [ __ ] and hoes
that want to slag after me and
i gotta bring him over like he has some
old man here and
yeah come on oh that's the urine oh my
god
yeah that's definitely someone's dead my
eyes were locked on the
finger uh protection thing when you said
nimbles yeah yeah yeah
thimbles that's what it's called show
the girls that girls love thimbles
heck yeah they play monopoly you always
won't be the thimbles the easiest one to
hang on to
put on your pinky finger you're the
thimbly monopoly
what do you pick the dogs the iron of
course
you pick it up it's so cute all right
anyway
just everything it's embarrassing oh god
cursed zombies everywhere
it's like old people i don't know how
much greg it's a nice house though i do
know that kevin and i
pay a pretty fair amount it's a large
three-bedroom condo so
wait he leaves there for free but he
makes his friends pay rent till in there
well probably not after they see this
video they're probably
what that is such a shitty move oh my
god
yeah he paid me some rent i live here
for not free
what take my roommates with me and
charge them rent even though i'm living
for free oh so he is and he's
gloating about it what what a nice pal
what a friend huh what a guy what a guy
ah someone else is like generous and
he's taking advantage of that that is
like
part of cheapskate that i hate so much
yeah
don't pass the savings on just to build
them all yourself all right
this is the kitchen um
all right where to begin there's no
point in paying for anything that you
should get for free in life
i never spend money on condiments
anytime you go to a restaurant
just take extra when you're there
i would never pay for paper plates or
any kind of plate really
he goes to random birthday parties hey
how old is your kid
you have a birthday party coming up oh
you have a birthday we need to grab a
couple plates
yeah happy birthday this is great happy
birthday balloons are you gonna need
those still
how long do you want that they're gonna
go
yeah what is that in the back he got
like random stuff from a party
birthday party there you go save money
on cups
um i actually reuse yogurt cups i got
this from my grandma
this way they're all labeled everybody
knows whose cups whose but if we get a
guest i actually give them the big
what so that makes no sense just have
glasses
and you can wash them does he know that
how much is glasses
probably is cheaper than yogurt he's
saving so much money man
he's got it he's got yours there right
there okay yeah i got one he asked me i
come over and see him
this dude's saving on condiments and
condoms because
hey how's he getting the date how does
this dude get to date no way
here you go here's the guest cup it's
the biggest one you get the big gulp
it's the big yoke
so it makes them feel special i don't
put them in the dishwasher because the
dishwasher wastes way too much money
uh electric and water so i just hand
wash they would crumble right oh it's
plastic isn't it
okay yeah i'm sure they're not
dishwasher
safe because why would they be right
there's no point in having a bulb inside
a refrigerator
i took the bulb out of the refrigerator
it saves me almost 40 dollars a year
nice you actually don't have to put the
bulb by you can literally just put some
tape over the
thing but okay dude wait wait hang on
forty dollars a year
to taking the ball is refreshing how do
they come up with that number it's
almost 40
a year in electric oh my god get out of
here
it saves me a thousand dollars at least
eating these yogurt glasses speaking
instead of glasses so you could probably
find someone left over somewhere i don't
know like what
you can just take glass from birthday
parties dude probably probably
the dead man's house they're living in
there's probably was some silverware
left over
yeah why would there not be glasses
there when i go shopping i always leave
the tags on the shirt because
you never know if it's going to go out
of style so always keep the tags and you
can just return them later
i paid for him it's not stealing if you
pay for it i'm living the dream
but how do you what do you have enough
clothes do you understand
right you don't need that many shirts
and also that you there's usually like
30 days and then you can't return them
anymore right
i mean he's worried about things going
out of style when was living the dream
t-shirt ever installed
was that his logic it's just going to
get out of sal yeah
no this guy's a pinnacle of fashion
obviously as soon as i'm done living the
dream
i just return it biggest money saver in
the whole condo
is right here in the bathroom greg
thinks that he lives a pretty normal
life and most other people would
probably think so too until they get to
know him
he takes showers with his clothes on
what
by watching clothes in the shower with
me i'm saving at least 15
a month because i don't have to use a
washer a dryer
soap when i take it
now this is a cheapskate does that
actually help
i just that makes no sense i can't he
he even has like a little plastic bag
over the tag do you see it under his arm
protect the tag protect the tag
oh god when he gets out of the shower
with his wet shirt on does he just like
stand around dripping water all over the
place
yeah air dry saves me money
get in there and it catches all the
excess water from me at the end of the
week when i'm running
that is disgusting all right well he's
definitely saving money on cleaning
supplies because that ring is
yeah what ah
flush the toilet i take that water and
he flushes with it into the toilet
and that's what causes the toilet to
flush
that way i'm not wasting any water
amazing
and that saves me at least four hundred
dollars a month
wow genius you know what else you know
what else is really great
good for you know money just getting a
real job and then enjoying your life
yeah
it's also a great way to you know
right if people did this kind of stuff
because they want a lifestyle
like maybe they don't want to they maybe
they want to live like out in the woods
or like in a special place or
then i can understand it but this is
this this guy just wants a cool car
by far the best part about online dating
is you don't have to spend money
on dinner and drinks and wasting gas
going places meeting people just get
online and
it's free this girl is kind of hot
she likes fancy restaurants and trailing
next that is so made up
get out what what websites he owned yeah
okay this this girl likes jewelry
next next this girl wants like a
kid oh those are expensive next
and here's one she likes shopping and
wine tasting
that's way too expensive
this seems so fake now that you say i
don't think anything this is real
this dude just wanted to be on the show
yeah right he has two roommates that are
but also the glasses it makes no sense
like why wouldn't the old guy
the guy left like everything on the
planet for
what freaking shirt back there
right yeah she likes camping oh and she
likes long
walks long walks are free
yeah he knows they are
wow take her to the park here you go
genius is he calling her right away
randy there
yeah hey um i saw your ad online
actually
um you look kind of cute i'm really
looking forward to meeting brandi
uh because we both met on a free dating
site do you want to go out tomorrow
yeah i'm assuming and hoping that she is
a cheapskate as well
i'll email you the address of the place
okay
okay all right talk to you later all
right
sorry felix the uh there's a hospital
next
like pretty close and their emergency
helicopter's taken off so you can
probably hear it whoa
oh that's just my helicopter outside
landing you know
damn i thought you were a cheapskate
yeah you know i've been saving up and
decided to spend a little money and i
got a used one of course with only
two blades because you know it'll still
fly i don't want to save some money
oh that's smart thanks tomorrow god it
sounds like
it sounds like you're getting swatted or
some [ __ ]
cops are coming to get you
we know the cheapskate secrets get down
do you think he's selling up stuff
from the guy like no one's going to know
he's going off
right i mean probably and the other
thing is
he just called this girl up and was like
hey i saw you online you want to go out
tomorrow
and she's like yeah without knowing
anything about him right
i'm sure that happened and that's a
great way to get murdered you know
okay girls don't do this i'm sure you
know already
i'm taking brandy to a barbecue
restaurant because it's much cheaper
than like a sushi place
but i'm hoping that she ate earlier so
she's not as hungry
i'm hoping is he going to convince her
what to order was that her
you probably just want some condiments
right you're not that hungry right yes
i'm great greg nice to meet you
she must know about the whole ordeal
with dlc she's got to because she's like
look
at her i mean she's not like yeah i
don't look at her and see
i was on a free dating website and then
random guy called me and i agreed to go
out with him kind of girl
right that makes sense yeah i can see
that this is someone he knows from the
zumba class or something
when i first met greg he seemed like a
nice guy sweet
typically i wouldn't be asked to go on
my first date at a barbecue place only
because it's
messy and he's more casual
i i know nothing about barbecue places
but apparently there's a stigma
seems like a fine place to go on a first
date i don't get it
it's like a place you go like with your
family like just to have like a cheap
meal they're like
your friends if you just want to sit
around and talk or you've been it's like
a pub
in 20 years yeah it's just it's yeah
it's not like a
wine and dying kind of place at all it's
just somewhere to eat right on a first
date who cares you don't want to have
fancy park's free you know
yeah the park is better this guy ain't
even saving money
how about something to drink can i have
a
sweet tea sweet tea is sweet tea free
refills on there
yes can i just get a water and it's a go
cup please
water in a taco yes so you can get an
extra cup
uh i'm not starving or not oh so like
you wanna like share a meal maybe
yeah we can do that okay did you see the
kids menu
everything it's only 4.95
all right they're going to share a kid's
menu
uh-huh okay is the part where an actual
day would just be like okay
all right i am not you're right you're
not gonna score
or you could get the uh sweet and sour
hot sauce for only 2.95
i've learned that greg doesn't like to
spend lots of money
there's nothing wrong with it just it's
different
the real chat move was to order like the
fattest thing you could get and just
make her
pay for it and be like right it's 20 21
equality let's
come on so how about you get me this
time and then the next day i'll get you
you know
yeah exactly exactly he doesn't want to
date women he just wants to have free
food
i bet so many girls do that i can't be
wrong for assuming that i'm sorry all
right dare you
no i bet they do that get out of here
someone's done that for sure
i have ladies at least one person i
i have heard from girls many times that
yeah they're not that into
the dude they just want some free food
[Music]
i i respect that it's a real thing maybe
not for everyone in the comment section
but it is a real thing
i heard it too i want some free food let
me just
go on tinder real quick i wish i could
do that
wait no don't marry him you privileged
women
how could you jacob advantage
you know what if i had to sit with this
[ __ ] guy i want to free me up
so i i get it if i if i had to go out
and eat with a
guy i don't know yeah it seems fair that
they would pay for it you all made the
choice
uh do you like the order yes yes i think
we're ready um i'm just
gonna take the pulled pork sandwich all
right that's pretty popular
that is not what we agreed on you were
supposed to get the salad and we were
supposed to
share it we were supposed to get the
chicken nuggets and
you had two and i would get two and then
the macaroni and cheese because the kids
plate
he's like i'm not paying for this this
is not what we agreed
i'm leaving this date's over oh is that
pretty good size the pulled pork
sandwich
it's a nice portion uh like big enough
for two probably just depends on how
hungry you are
i'm not real hungry right no okay
perfect never hungry right
okay does he understand that this isn't
gonna change anything like being and
you're just being annoying
like how big is that yeah okay yeah cool
can we both eat it
it's not gonna become bigger because you
ask about the science support
god at least he's not haggling with her
like okay yeah can we get that but for
uh oh
5.99 i don't know about that how about
you know 99 cents
you like uh a racker ribs no just like
one rib
the wrap is like kind of expensive and i
didn't know if she would like it so i
thought maybe we'd just get one
just in case okay so you'd like one how
do you get one right
these guys when they ask they just cut
what let's give you one i guess
they can probably see one i doubt they
can but the camera's there so they can
do anything with the camera
right they really want to impress
or show off and so it's just it was
different to see him
really not care oh she's into it he's so
different
here's your one rib that looks good and
here's
your one rib all right nice did you want
to try some of those
um no that's okay it's okay you want to
try some of this
you mean have the whole thing like what
do you
what oh
god there's not a lot there what is that
painting that is the most hideous thing
i've ever seen
what the hell the pig is like why'd you
eat me
all right that's really good though yeah
what do you want they do it different in
ohio
oh yeah actually right okay maybe a
little bit of pork too
yeah well we'll just do about oh yeah
all right how about yeah yeah i'll try
yeah i'm paying for it right girl so
come on hand it over you know what's up
it's like you're a restaurant and you
want to try someone else's meal and then
you just grab the whole [ __ ] thing
okay i'll try that thanks thanks for
letting me try it
oh that would be nice thank you
so what else do you do besides save
cups and utensils what else uh at my
condo
like the same morning on water we only
flush once a week i save like thirty
dollars more fees
things you shouldn't say on a date
example
one i flush once a week oh
think back to the rings in his toilet oh
god i believe him that he only flushes
once we but
in a house with three dudes
how do you get by with flushing once a
week
oh god it's got it dude i poop at least
three times a day
it's like goddamn we had taco bell last
night oh
oh roger really filled it up i don't
know if i'll be able to squeeze this one
in here
if they flush once a week there's got to
be a whole mountain there
you like you sit you sit down and you
just sit on the other poop you know
you get like you got like a hover so you
don't get that's when they know it's
time to flush
like well we better get the shower flush
this down watch that [ __ ]
there's no way you'll get stopped up
every time to be way too much
oh man
so you guys go to the bathroom the whole
week and you don't flush
no i just hold it i soar my poop
i bet he does that way yes it doesn't
have to flush as much that makes sense
at least just throw it out maybe i
already know or hide it somewhere in
the dead grandpa's house i'm like oh god
that's pretty disgusting
if you come out raleigh you flush
[Music]
once that's nice
that's nice you think that she's going
to go she's not coming over
she ain't
that's how he wants to live his life
it's good for him just too extreme for
me i would never do it
here are all the things you asked for
thank you let me know if anything else
you need
okay thank you sure all right
he's cleaning them out i don't like the
waste food are you gonna eat the food
oh yeah absolutely all right oh yeah
girl
all that but you can never have too much
barbecue sauce
what you're just stealing at this point
oh don't forget
no it's free man it's free greg is a
very sweet guy
funny a little cheap but oh my gosh a
little cheap
don't don't yeah don't don't you don't
have to do it he just told you that he
flushes his toilet once a week
yeah disgusting yeah how many times a
week he brushes teeth
oh god i bet he doesn't thank you
for taking me out i'll never see you
again for me
well i had a lot of fun tonight would
you want to go out again sometime yeah i
did i had a good time thank you
she said all right i guess the camera's
going i
this is the fakest crap no i don't know
yeah
there's no way there's no way no way
i mean maybe there is a way until she
sees like a t-shirt collection that says
like
living the dream and she's like okay
yeah you're you're mentally 12 still so
no
no he's a little cheap i could look past
that and definitely
he's a really sweet guy so i would
definitely go out with greg again
what are you what if somebody doesn't
like you for who you are then you
shouldn't be with them
i mean he's right about that yeah
yeah so this is supposed to be the cheap
world's cheapest date
but it wasn't even get out of here they
still pay like 10 bucks
if i was one of this roommate i'd offer
to pay extra just for the toilet boot of
life
well if it's 40 bucks i ain't paying 40
bucks just to flush
when i lived back back in my day when i
lived in america
my big old house we freaking i had the
shot i sat in the shower and let the
water run
forever the most my water bill ever was
was 20 20
right i use the water all the time right
how does it make where did i get these
numbers from
no no freaking they they need to start
bagging this water up and
keeping its precious you know what would
save you money if you've been in the
shower
what nothing
what nothing at all okay in you know a
way you don't have to flush
no you know you you complain about these
memes right that stick to you and they
get annoying
are you you again i'm just saying
shut up i mean you see it you save on
toilet paper too because you know you
just rinse it off and you're done
yeah dude i was thinking yesterday you
know there's always these conspiracies
of companies
doing [ __ ] so that they'll [ __ ] you over
right toilet paper companies they must
be lobbying politicians
to not create three days
so that what they are still running
in 2020 whenever covet hit and the
freaking huge killer hornets or whatever
and everybody started buying all the
toilet paper
me and mary bought a bidet oh like the
attachment to the toilet
it was like it wasn't even that
expensive it was it was pretty
inexpensive and it worked great
yeah there you go we can't do that here
because the toilets don't have
like that right yeah open thing these
australian toilets i couldn't react
there's no way i could ever plug
anything into it yet so that's why i'm
like
australia and you care part of this
toilet paper conspiracy where they're
paying the toilet manufacturers to not
make it so you can install
the bidet in them and i'm pretty sure
that me and my family go through like a
whole roll of toilet paper a day i don't
know what
back home when i got that show on the
plus you know like one freaking roll
lasted like a week and now
i ain't touching finger poop no i gotta
have a
good grip on that how much toilet paper
do you use you get like a
whole wad i go wild because my parents
would always tell me to
fold the paper so you can get a double
wipe out of it they would insist on it
oh so so yeah you know so now that i'm
an adult
i use two squares toilet paper i want
that you get two squares
you fold it in half so your finger don't
slip you know that's all you need
but i mean if you're not jesus not
not not doing that i mean when you get
to the point where like you're you know
you're almost done with it i can see
like
you know double wiping a little bit with
the same piece but i don't know man you
know when
when it's fresh you know what i'm saying
you don't want to be i don't know what
you're saying
it ain't happening yeah no way god dang
don't have that problem together yeah
i'm glad to very nice
told a lot of secrets here today that uh
don't share it to anyone guys
well did we really just turn an
eight-minute clip into a
freaking 45 minutes jesus
i'm so sorry every time sees my files
he's got to be like
god dang it this [ __ ] ken guy again
we're still doing it we're adding more
to it if today's your birthday happy
birthday
thank you for watching subscribe check
out cam we got more tfc stuff over there
and then daddy bye bye you stole my
birthday thing
if your name is my daddy stay tuned my
friends
you thought it was dead but true
relevance
never really died welcome to the first
undead game use any item in your
inventory and make
memes inside tuber simulator add some of
our patented stickers in there
stickers our emotions memes our emotions
express still emotions
show them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows maybe i'll review your
memes the greatest honor of all time
circle baby download it make a meme
we need subtitles on this